the world of sports continues its fight
against doping the president of the
International Olympic Committee has made
a very honest and a very sad admission
hoping will always happen this is one of
the walls you cannot win those words did
not sit well with the chief of the US
anti-doping agency Travis Tygart it's
obviously a tough fight but the leader
of sport or anti-doping can't simply
throw in the towel he probably has a
point
especially since doping scandals have
hit Taggarts own turf
just this week alone to us athletes
received lengthy bans for substance
abuse
that's while pundits blame anti-doping
officials for turning a blind eye when
it comes to domestic sport or rather
multi-billion businesses like the NFL
but Thomas back strong words weren't the
trigger for you saddest criticism Tygart
assumed that the IOC presidents quote
was essentially a precursor to water
reinstating the Russian anti-doping
agency at the meeting scheduled for
September 20th but did say that he hoped
Russia had learned it's lesson the hard
way and would be welcomed back into the
world of sports and that was something
Tygart stressed must not happen but be a
devastating blow to Russia's excuse me
to widest credibility as well as the
hopes and dreams of millions of athletes
around the world who believe in clean
and fair competition Russia and its
anti-doping agency have been imprisoned
for several years now after the
publication of the so-called McLaren
report which detailed accusations of a
state-sponsored doping program the
result many Russian athletes banned the
country's anti-doping agency effectively
shut down and wada handing over a
lengthy criteria list for resada
to be reinstated last year the agency
acknowledged that 19 of 31 points had
been met and just this month the
president of wada said there were only
two conditions remaining two of 31 but
they still had to be purified I think
relationships are goods to the point
that we have yet to purify the two
conditions that are still outstanding
sure more needs to be done with new
akiza
and new anti-doping investigations
Russia still has three weeks to put
things right
so has Tiger jumped the gun in demanding
Russia to be kept out the final two
criteria we're talking about Russia is
supposed to say hands up
the McLaren report was right we did
engage in state-sponsored doping Russia
is absolutely rejected the McLaren
reports finding not because they don't
believe he brushes quite rightly said we
want the evidence Thomas Bach himself
has requested the evidence and so far
nobody has seen it apart we presume from
McLaren it is only a guess at this stage
but I think the first steps to a
reinstatement will be taking place
towards the end of September when there
is a big meeting of water and I think
that the the outcome will be that Russia
will be readmitted I don't think it will
be an unconditional reinstatement but
eventually I think people will just have
to say well okay Russia are not
admitting that there's been
state-sponsored doping but we need them
anyway they are a world power in sports
and sport needs Russia keeping sport
clean is something that both the IOC
president and head of US anti-doping
agency are striving to achieve but can
you really demand one thing from another
country when similar doping scandals
break out in your own backyard one
thing's for sure the next water meeting
in the Seychelles is looking like
politics and doping will go down the
finish line
you